we went ahead and kind of took some content that we already had it's not great content so don't
overthink it don't read through too much of the content that we have prepared this is just to
show you how we add the content to your website so we have our Weebly page open okay let's start
with the first paragraph I keep opening the wrong one there you go okay just going to copy
website right here is the first paragraph and you're going to paste it okay make sure
it's online to the side so it doesn't look silly we can definitely add a couple we usually like
this content to the same length of the quote next to it so let's go and grab a couple more
sentences from below and an easy way to you know because then you're like okay which part
which sentence did I copy and paste it which one did I not so I usually highlight in yellow what
I've already copied and pasted that way I don't duplicate the content on the website okay this
seems enough make it yellow go ahead and copy that in here okay that looks fine now right here
we put a page title so what could a page title be actually let's let's copy all the content and
then we'll go ahead and make things pretty copy that bring it back here don't know why
you did that no because it's the page title I'm gonna put that into the text there you go
and again don't read through our content too much it is just a very simple that we were not
going to use so it's not it's not great content it's just to show you how to structure it once
it's on the website
we can you can go on and build more like I would probably like to add probably a little more down
here put a little spacer in there
I think I already copied that yep okay
I like to leave the very last sentences I'll show you how I usually use it copy make it yellow
I'm going to copy that here okay the very last few letters I actually like to align them in the
center I'll show you what that looks like so we can add that's a little too much so I'm going to
you I'm going to just copy this part yeah okay add it down here I'm going back okay the very
last sentence I liked it to be something like hey give us a call for a free instant quote hey
if you want to get a free instant estimate on your concrete project give us a call or fill out the
quote form right above something that catches that actually makes them do somewhat of an action and
to contact us that's usually how you want it to end because people are not going to look at the
very likely nobody's going to read anything of what you wrote but they're definitely going to
look at the header where there's a big phone number and possibly at the bottom because when
you go and look for a website we usually look at the bottom then we scroll scroll scroll to see the
ending and then you look at the ending you don't look anything that's in between so we put those
words and I actually like to align them in the middle perfect and I went ahead and copied the
tracking number that I had from Coral okay now how do we structure it we kind of already structured
it doesn't look bad this is definitely not even 2,000 words so yours is probably going to look
more lengthy let's add some titles and the titles they probably want to be something that's a keyword
so post this doc I'm going back to our keyword list we have extended um you can probably put
something like concrete contractors let's get some ideas from Google I like that is a concrete
driveway worth it and again some of these you're actually going to have once you write the content
so like how I did that what is seemed concrete driveway that could be a title so is what was
the sentence is concrete driver worth it okay and then we have one more again add a couple more if
you have obviously you're probably going to have more content so go ahead and grab add more make
it more structural so and more titles and the title can be a long tail keyword list it could
also be just a short tail keyword so it could just be like stamped concrete could be a title
so get creative it could also be the name of your company if you haven't used it in your content
it could literally be Queen Creek concrete contractors or Queen Creek concrete that's it
we already put that one we could put what are the pros
okay there you go so just make sure that the structure once you're done copying the content
actually looks like a structure professionally like you have a little bullet list here and there
you can add more bullet lists you are adding see this is my bad this is actually you have some
titles you have your phone number added on it and then what I like to do because we now need to
link the phone number as a click to call so when people see the phone number right here I want
them to be able to click it and call directly because if they're looking at this from the phone
and that's something that I like to do consistently while I'm adding the content or really doing
anything on the website is to okay so if you see this don't get alarmed so see how our first
paragraph is gone because it should be before the quote form the reason why is because we have not
added the corner image yet so because we don't have this corner image here it's actually canceling
this out so don't worry about it yet as soon as we optimize it we'll do that in the next video we
optimize we add images this will show up on the mobile section as well so let's just look make
sure that everything looks good from the phone number from the phone screen okay that looks good
to me perfect now it's let's inner link within your website and let's link the phone number so
I see the phone number here copy oops highlight the phone number copy click the link phone and
and put the same phone number click out of it okay see that now it's linked to a phone
okay we probably want to make this bold and a color
if you go on theme and change fonts and links this is you definitely want to change this so
the link color I would probably do either a red or blue so people know that it's a link and they
can click on it okay and then when you're going over with your mouse I would probably
keep the same slightly darker and again this is up to you on how you want to do it okay so see
when you hover that I don't know why that's not showing it doesn't really matter and what you can
actually do is just copy this phone number because you already linked it it's ready good to go I
click command F if you're a macbook type 480 to find any other phone number that you put in
here there it is and I'm just going to paste that format that we made that way it's already linked
we don't have to do this again all right now last part is inner linking so inner linking is if you
know what a backlink is it's a similar idea but instead of doing a backlink outside of your website
with other websites you're just interlinking it within your own connecting every page to each
other so if someone ends up in on the corporate driveway they can roll into the home page and
every other page okay and how you do that's pretty simple so we usually do three inner links per
page and you usually want to keep a you usually want to pick a keyword that's what you're going
to interlink so we have a stamped concrete service page so I am going to select stamping concrete
interlink it to a standard page and I'm going to interlink it to our service page for stamped
concrete that's it now we need a driveway one and again it doesn't need to be the same exact like
you can put the driveway concrete in the link to link to be linked to the company's name standard
page that's your concrete patio and then let's do one more and you want to do this for each page
and make sure you are covering you're not doing the same two pages back and forth you're doing
all of the pages here are the concrete services
perfect and you're done make sure you can also change let's say you go dark let's say you go
dark here you added the background and you want the background to be dark make sure you're changing
the font to be white obviously and you do that again you can change the font and everything right
here paragraph text you can change and you can make it bigger it does look a little tiny it's
black I actually don't think that's black it's a charcoal so we'll make it more black should be more
clear
better spacing
line height
there you go
you can switch it up
pick whatever
let me pick one that's pretty clear
let's just keep this one and make sure you publish save and obviously keep doing that for all of
your other service pages as well and you're done